de lice explain to me why you gave it
who would have thought names for louis
review score of 2014 is it really that
we have been arguing only to some pretty
we've given something there have been
three threes okay
Faceman good let's turn that big old to
bass we call something else something
yeah basement crawl was this year
yeah wow there you go time flies can i
know right flies when you're not have
laying have so even so it doesn't it
took reinstall the reason I gave daily
the three is because I think it's a bad
game okay yeah yeah but then I like
scary games
alright I'm really let's say I guess I
should hop right anything hop right in
if you have any questions at all for
Kevin about their lives as ever used the
chat use the comment box let's do it
just tweet is that case but new story
the very beginning is it can is it visit
you're gonna be dark so this is your
game from zombie studios this is a
first-person har type game what and that
uses apparently it's some sort of
procedural generated stuff going on
there is some procedural generation not
in this first opening area this is gonna
be the same every time but when you
start getting into the labyrinths where
a lot of the gameplay takes place things
start getting a little bit different
sometimes okay sometimes it's gonna like
you're gonna go on these different like
is it just a different floor layout
different enemy placement different
puzzle or layout the puzzles are always
the same
okay this really isn't a puzzle game
this is more about this is more like if
you've played slender the arrival or
something like that you do get this this
this instance where you have these
ghostly spirits and sneaking up on you
and you take damage from them okay what
I what I kind of consider it to be like
insanity damage or something like that
sanity damage so do you get like cool
insanity effects like in everyone's
favorite insanity game it took a lot no
nothing nothing quite like that there
are some surprise moments that come out
where where you do see things you didn't
expect like oaths but like well you
would expect ghosts though
so you you like dead animals pictures of
dangers of dead animals yeah mostly the
the gameplay comes down to you walking
around and picking stuff up okay um
stuff like what ghosts stuff stuff like
right you know anything that's a it's
they're all they're all called remnants
so they're remnants of the past it could
be a memo like here on a memo written by
one of the doctors or nurses here in
this now abandoned Hospital mm-hmm and
now you see we found a glowstick humane
mechanics one is the glow stick oh so
this is also an eighties rave simulator
yes absolutely
yeah can you start spinning that but
what's the button for pop LSD and then
you see that whenever you have a glow
stick the items that you can interact
with glow you don't know what happened
your arm what's that stuff on your arm
tattoos it's unclear that it's a towel
in the game it's a towel that's nice so
this is a game that is meant to be
played multiple times that's what they
say okay it is because it's procedurally
generated and so supposedly there are
different things that happen there's
also this weird twitch integration where
if you're streaming to your twitch
channel people can type things like
scream yes cat and things like that and
make scary noises happen at goob shoe
rias's asked on twitch have any twitch
commands have you found I know that
scream works that meow works okay what
happens is that was scary well I guess
it's all in the delivery
there are you can type in light and the
light goes out there's something you can
type in to do here's one of the most
here's my favorite moment in the game
actually oh my
freaky Calliope yeah so I let you go I
like that moment that's pretty freaky
but baby grim train wreck and there's so
this is I believe the first commercially
available on your engine for game why
yes yes it is yeah does it look better
than this later it looks okay it looks
totally fine but it always looks like
this okay it always more or less looks
like this oh what's that thing there's a
the person said here you see you got to
avoid that's the end there's a dead out
but she's disappeared we use the modern
baking yeah there's there's you can pick
up flares and hopefully I'll pick up a
flare in a moment so you can see there I
just picked up a flare when she gets
close you can light the flare and burn
her away oh my and now you see that glow
sticks out I like to bait another dog I
don't like this part there you go there
you go okay how's this game genuinely
scared you at least on the first way
through yeah the first time there were a
couple scares that got to me especially
when I turned around and there she is
like with her big gaping face got a gay
pee face he does have kind of a Gabey
face like one of the top three creepy
faces there is you know like light
coming out of her eye holes
ah yeah and so here you go through and
this is about like piecing together the
story
all right piece together the story yes I
have pieced the story together eight
eight times now so this this is actually
my ninth my ninth playthrough Wieck
there we go
piggy button prompts well so you're
grabbing all these things right and of
course the the notes lying around to you
know a DIN exposition is a well-worn
video game trope the one that always
comes to mind to me that like genuinely
freaked me out was when I was playing
Resident Evil and there's the the
journal you get of like the the person
that girl or someone who's like they are
the guy who's slowly going insane yeah
and then you get to itchy tasty yeah
which is just like it sounds absurd what
do you say it but like you're reading it
in context is eerie I you're of course
blowing through this for the sake of the
demo but like how what's your overall
impressions of the stuff that you end up
reading of the the world that it sort of
informs you like it's a complete
mishmash oh and that's that's one of the
games real problems is that is that it
tells a bunch of stories it's not
telling just one story really it's
pretty much every horror cliche you can
think of jammed into into ninety minutes
in your review I actually laughed when
you mentioned ancient Indian burial
ground I could not believe that that was
that was available voice is built on an
ancient evil there's where you go later
to a construction project that's then
and and and as it turns out it was being
built on an ancient bureaus burial
ground but there are notes from like the
facilities people who who were all like
yeah I can't you know I I don't know
what would look the weird sounds at
night and and you know the the patients
of the mental asylum and and and notes
you know from doctors saying this and
that and the other and the weird
behaviors and Jun you get out three
styles and entries and yeah the but the
but the problem is that like it's it's
all telling it's like just a mishmash of
stuff like it you know and now I don't
know nine playthroughs later and I don't
know that I have a real good handle on
everything but a good enough handle to
know that it's that it's not worth care
it's just like horror hodgepodge not
enough to like come together and form a
cohesive place that you can actually
like get a little bit immersed into
imagine like because I feel like so much
of these games is that sure you can do
jump scares you can set the tone but as
like a whole the thing that gets me
about horror is that my imagination like
outpaces yeah and so like the best
horror games I think sort of set your
imagination running hmm and you just
start imagining all the freaky crap that
can happen to you have you compared to
see games like I don't know at last or
or m/c or something like that yeah well
they're both better games number one but
outlast was one of my top ten personal
games from last year okay so you're
familiar with the finer points of this
genre yeah I really really liked outlast
and and this game has some shades of
outlast for like four steps only are you
just doing that to like stop and look in
worse you can here we go here's is the
reason is I'm lost and because I'm so
far away from the TV I couldn't quite
tell where I was on the map okay so
you're just checking around corners you
can't you could I can just run forever
yeah you can sprint forever in this game
which is conducive to terror and that's
so you can just outpace the ghost
yeah I check me out I'm who saying boat
mama well I know one of the problems
with I mean in this area that stuff's
not so bad because you have to backtrack
and stuff and you turn around and she
might be there okay but when you get
into the forest which is which is open
there's nothing really to be afraid of
because as long as you keep sprinting
and don't turn around you're never gonna
get caught okay right now I'm looking
for the sigil so this now that I have
down at the bottom right you can see how
many remnants I have it requires not a
six for me to move into the next area
but in order to do that I have to go
pick up the sigil which is the key
you're all being here right that's so
here's the teddy bear and you know
there's another hard cliche and weird
phrase a weird old freaky teddy bear
little kids inverted color oh and and
viruses yes that's kinda dude on the
phone talking to you yeah you've got him
a little here salt
he's coming yeah he's coming through oh
here's one of those uh did you just get
like jump cutted yeah I got jump cut
into a different area but this is the
past is there some sort of supposed like
see you see these they're eventually you
see they're like twelve all of these
pictures on the walls just drunk she's
locked and there we go
oh my getting a fear Alma kind of vibe
off some of those bits as well yeah
first encounter assault recon of course
but what's hello of course there's the
counter floor because yes now I know now
I know the game is how its storied
sequel first encounter assault recon two
and it's that the sequel to that game
which is of course a 300 yeah first
three in character recon recon so now I
can't use glow sticks or or flares or
anything while I have a sigil in my hand
okay sorry I got two hands yeah
obviously so at this stage I'm just
running to get to the exit can you turn
the twitch stuff on on any stage no
unfortunately you have to be it's it's a
little complex how does it work you have
to what you have to stream separately
outside of the game so whatever it is
that you use to stream you stream that
way and then once you're streaming you
then go into the games
you okay and and join the two you can't
stream directly from the game you only
drive connection but apparently twitch
is damn for scheduled maintenance right
now anyway so oh good times matter so
now you've seen the firsts I guess the
first fifth of the game great I haven't
seen a ghost yet Kevin no you saw her
that one time okay like glancing limbs
girl imps but that's one of the problems
with the always run thing is that I've
done this enough times loads of glow
sticks as well yeah you're never at a
loss if you play on medium you're never
lost so every section is kind of like
the same you have sort of a safe area
like this one where you're not gonna
encounter a ghost and where the remnants
don't mean anything they're just picking
up stories is that like him you know the
way those things glow under the glow
sticks is that because they're covered
in like bodily fluids yeah like a black
light yeah so I think we follow the sage
as a covered and seeing what I didn't
show here is Elijah seaman I jump in
here and and peed all over everything
oh that's a scripted flyby go shooter
with a flare yeah that did freak me out
yeah is she the one that's putting ghost
semen on everything um I prefer not to
answer boilers haven't kid neither
confirm nor here's another another
scripted sequence here okay
this lady seemed distressed and also not
of this world
her face is really it's just the dark
night incident report so of course this
is patient was acting weird on entry
yeah
you can't put a ghost semen everywhere
really weird patient custodial staff
continues its a cabal kinda lame
so now here's one of the games very few
puzzles so it's a box pushing puzzle it
is a box pushing puzzle alright
there's much combat in this there is no
combatant okay but you do have to use
the flares to keep the ghosts away time
so that could be is that timing base you
need to let go ha well no if you
suddenly if you see here I just reach
quick so that I don't take any more
damage or if I hear her or finds me yeah
so here's another bit what happens if
you get damaged to the max you die and
you start at the you start at the
beginning of whatever area you're you're
in at that time uh what if they did you
know how like pray did that thing where
you die you have to go to the ghosts
realm and like fight your way back what
if they did something in a horror game
we're like you die and you like become
on a more horrible place or something
like because all the souls who died in
these horrible places they just become
part of the horror scene right yeah what
I don't know just realize pray is the
last game that did that probably I'm
sure does a game that's done well
Borderlands has the kind of like dude
you're down but you can get your second
win by killing an enemy while you're
down is what that's not really this game
is so interesting we're talking about
pray sorry I got a I got to open the
door the door now opens okay and now
this is where you basically get into the
next scary area okay so this is Gary
we've got a minute cavity will this is
scare more more a door if I don't see
like loads of go see more die lower Rose
door this is all that's not what I said
but I think that's what I should have
said yeah he's the horror you're in a
new scarier and what we're walking down
the horror door with your I can't think
of a one for glowsticks you guys with my
Molly
oh god no sticks no no we're not letting
any more okeydoke alright so I've found
hey me already yeah but I I can't do
anything so just the god is this I at
least that you know at the very least
Danny I appreciate your follow-through
thank you yeah dedication dedication the
semen is appreciated amongst us all good
probably a good thing twitches damn
right now where's the next ghost I don't
know I'm going through that makes it
scary there is a threat meter right now
it's blank
okay like you see that give a wise
leader well you have a threat app on
your phone down at the bottom right of
the screen next to the remnant can I get
this list can I get this and then walk
down to the mission at nighttime and
here blink at me what is that what's the
thing called in Ghostbusters the the
center thingy ecto-1 PK PK v oh my god
Jeff Gerstmann dropping a knowledge bomb
yeah you need to get that app you get PK
e Rick meter is it can I just say that I
support the release Kevin from historian
Kenneth E is so much of this game now I
want nothing more than since of people
and it's differently set free for my
procedure it's different every time